this conversation with john abramson is
a critical exploration of the
pharmaceutical industry
i wanted to talk to john in order to
provide a countervailing perspective to
the one expressed in my podcast episode
with the ceo of pfizer albert berla
and here please allow me to say a few
additional words about this episode with
the pfizer ceo
and in general about why i do these
conversations and how i approach them
if this is not interesting to you please
skip ahead
what do i hope to do with this podcast
i want to understand human nature
the best and the worst of it
i want to understand how power money and
fame changes people
i want to understand why atrocities are
committed by crowds that believe they're
doing good
all this ultimately because i want to
understand how we can build a better
world together
to find hope for the future
and to rediscover each time
through the exploration of ideas
just how beautiful this life is
this our human civilization in all of
its full complexity the forces of good
and evil of war and peace of hate and
love
i don't think i can do this with a heart
and mind that is not open fragile and
willing to empathize with all human
beings
even those in the darkest corners of our
world
to attack is easy
to understand
is hard
and i choose the hard path
i have learned over the past few months
that this path involves me getting more
and more attacked from all sides
i will get it to act when i host people
like jay baracharya or francis collins
jamie mertzel or vincent ruckinello
when i stand for my friend joe rogan
when i host tech leaders like mark
zuckerberg elon musk and others
when i eventually talk to vladimir putin
barack obama and other figures that have
turned the tides of history
i have and i will get called stupid
naive
weak
and i will take these words with respect
humility and love
and i will get better
i will listen think learn and improve
one thing i can promise
is there's no amount of money or fame
they can buy my opinion or make me go
against my principles
there's no amount of pressure
that can break my integrity
there's nothing in this world i need
that i don't already have
life itself is the fundamental gift
everything else is just a bonus
that is freedom
that is happiness
if i die today
i will die a happy man
now
a few comments about my approach and
lessons learned from the albert berla
conversation the goal was to reveal as
much as i could about the human being
before me and to give him the
opportunity to contemplate in long-form
the complexities of his role including
the tension between making money and
helping people
the corruption that so often permeates
human institutions the crafting of
narratives through advertisements and so
on
i only had one hour
so this wasn't the time to address these
issues deeply but to show if albert
struggled with them in the privacy of
his own mind
and if he would let down the veil of
political speak for a time to let me
connect with a man who decades ago chose
to become a veterinarian
who wanted to help lessen the amount of
suffering in the world
i had no pressure placed on me there
were no rules the questions i was asking
were all mine and not seen by pfizer
folks i had no care whether i ever
talked to another ceo again
none of this was part of the calculation
in my limited brain computer
i didn't want to grill him the way
politicians grill ceos in congress i
thought that this approach is easy
self-serving dehumanizing and it reveals
nothing
i wanted to reveal the genuine
intellectual struggle vision and
motivation of a human being and if that
fails i trusted the listener to draw
their own conclusion and insights from
the result whether it's the words spoken
or the words left unspoken or simply the
silence
and that's just it i fundamentally trust
the intelligence of the listener
you
in fact if i criticize the person too
hard or celebrate the person too much i
feel i fail to give the listener a
picture of the human being that is
uncontaminated by my opinion or the
opinion of the crowd
i trust that you have the fortitude and
the courage to use your own mind to
empathize and to think
two practical lessons i took away first
i will more strongly push for longer
conversations of three four or more
hours versus just one hour 60 minutes is
too short for the guests to relax and to
think slowly and deeply and for me to
ask many follow-up questions or follow
interesting tangents
ultimately i think it's in the interest
of everyone including the guests that we
talk in true long form for many hours
second these conversations with leaders
can be aided by further conversations
with people who wrote books about those
leaders or their industries
those that can steal man each
perspective and attempt to give an
objective analysis
i think of teddy roosevelt's speech
about the man in the arena i want to
talk to both the men and women in the
arena
and the critics and the supporters in
the stands
for the former i lean toward wanting to
understand one human being's struggle
with the ideas
for the latter i lean towards
understanding the ideas themselves
that's why i wanted to have this
conversation with john abramson who is
an outspoken critic of the
pharmaceutical industry i hope it helps
add context and depth to the
conversation i had with the pfizer ceo
in the end i may do worse than i could
have or should have
always i will listen to the criticisms
without ego and i promise i will work
hard to improve
but let me say finally
that cynicism is easy
optimism
true optimism is hard
it is the belief that we can
and we will
build a better world
and that we can only do it together
this is the fight worth fighting
so here we go once more into the breach
dear friends
i love you all
you